pourquoi dites vous que le racisme anti
blanc n'existe pas en france je dis ça
parce qu en fait personne en france ne
décroche pas un job ne décroche pas un
appartement se voit contrôlé par les
policiers systématiquement parce qu'il
est blanc on peut se faire agresser se
faire traiter de sale blanc ça existe je
nie pas du tout ce phénomène il ya des
phénomènes de violence d'agression qui
peuvent exister ok on peut en parler
mais le racisme ne sais pas ça le
racisme c'est une norme qui est établi
sur la base d'une couleur de peau
puisqu'on parle de deux races évidemment
les races biologique n'existe pas mais
dans le regard des gens le fait d'être
blanc ou noir ça ça peut exister et à
partir de là oui vous pouvez être plus
ou moins discriminée plus ou moins exclu
donc non ce actuellement en france il ne
peut pas y avoir de racisme anti blanc
alors expliquez vous que cette
expression s'impose dans le débat public
la preuve c'est que nous allons au débat
que ce soit parce que vous avez quelque
chose qui est assez étonnant depuis
quelques années vous avez une espèce de
renversement de la charge de la preuve
vous avez des gens qui essaient de
dénoncer le racisme qui essaie
d'expliquer ce qu'ils vivent en tant que
personne n'en racisées et à partir de là
puisque eux sentent le regard des autres
sans que l'exclusion définissent se
définissent comme racisées met
effectivement la question de la race au
sens social dans le débat public et tout
d'un coup les gens se disent ah mais
alors ça voudrait dire que finalement
peut-être nous on pourrait être rejetée
parce que blanc nous on serait différent
enfin on fait une différence en fonction
de cette couleur de peau mais ceux qui
vivent le racisme qui la vivent tous les
jours cette différence est effectivement
aujourd'hui on revit on réintroduit des
débats autour de cela avec plus de force
parce que avant on a souvent passé ça
sous le silence en tout cas dans le
débat public c'était quelque chose qui
avait un peu disparu et là ça revient
donc sari aviv sarah vit ces débats
c'est pour ça qu'on va en parler ce soir
j'imagine alors qu'on répondra
parlementaire médiatique un avocat
médiatique gilles william goldnadel
alors vous êtes huit jeux tous nos
chroniqueurs doivent se prononcer
existe-t-il un racisme anti blanc mettez
vos pancartes vous il william goldnadel
vous dites la négation du racisme anti
blanc relève de la névrose collective
c'est un raciste qui étrangement ne
soulève pas la même indignation que les
autres comme s'ils étaient moins gras
donc pour vous il n'ya pas de doute le
racisme anti blanc existe franchement se
poser même la question pardonnez moi je
ne veux pas être désagréable c'est
stupide le racisme c'est la chose la
mieux partagée au monde je ne vois pas
au nom de quoi les non blancs ne serait
pas raciste donc déjà mais moi quand
j'ai écrit réflexions sur la question
blanche il ya dix ans le fait même de
poser la question il ya ou de dire qui
vient racisme anti blanc c'était
racistes à l'époque maintenant je crois
que plus personne de sérieux pardon de
le dire comme ça ne le nie non mais
personne ne le nie alors il ya danger le
débat commence bien non mais écoutez il
n'a pas la même forme il n'a pas la même
forme c'est pas le un blanc n'a pas dû
mal à trouver un appartement mais
aujourd'hui je parle même pas aux états
unis vous avez le leader faraco rend la
nation vis l'âme il fait l'éloge adolf
hitler il est carrément racistes
anti-blancs mais ici culturellement le
racisme anti blanc il est massive parce
que le blanc le mal était homosexuel
blanc est considéré aujourd'hui comme le
méchant moi j'avais mon explication il
existe une sourde content d'être blanc
depuis qu on partage la même couleur de
peau que l'antéchrist moderne adolf
hitler c'est dans l'inconscient
collectif
mais je pense franchement que ce
l'explication mais culturellement il n'y
a pas de doute les corps les camps
racisées interdit aux blancs quand vous
avez une corinne maspero qui dans le
milieu artistique modeuses se moque des
blancs catholiques au au césar tout
toute une littérature explique le
privilège blanc explique d'une certaine
manière le racisme sur et blanc le main
le mâle blanc si j'ose dire donc
aujourd'hui avec la montée de par
contamination de la culture works
qui vient des états unis ce racisme là
il est massif et effectivement on peut
parfaitement être raciste anti blanc et
avoir totalement la cote c'est
incroyable pour ma part que le président
de la république est remis à spike lee
la légion d'honneur n'est ce pas alors
que ce pack lits venaient de faire
l'éloge de sarah cannes le qui avait
fait l'éloge canal fit tout pour revenir
à la france et pour sortir un peu de la
théorie pour la pratiquement il défend
des des gens savent qu'ils se disent
victimes entre autres médaillés jeunesse
victime de racisme anti noir noir mais
qu'est ce que ils viennent de se
plaindre de quoi qu'est ce qui leur est
arrivé par exemple si on veut illustrer
ce propos mais vous êtes vous allez
trouver peut-être ça saugrenue mais de
la même manière qu'un noir nous n'aime
pas être traité de sale [ __ ] il y à des
blancs qui n'aiment pas être traité
d'enculé leblanc parce que c'est souvent
c'est souvent cette phase d' [ __ ]
blanc 1 ou 2 ou de back to de tout ce
que vous voulez et donc danser des gens
qui se sont fait un sur dix et qui
viennent comme se sentent d'ailleurs
souvent en situation minoritaire dans
certains quartiers et qui il arrive
quelquefois que l'insultent soit
également accompagné de quelques coups
donc il convient de voir on est venu me
voir pour me dire je me suis fait
dérouiller je me suis fait traiter pour
le même prix de sale blanc et je dois
dire qu'aujourd'hui je ne trouve pas que
les tribunaux certains tribunaux soient
aussi réactif en ce qui concerne les
blancs qu'en ce qui concerne d'autres
non mais ça ça représente quoi je suis
capable sympa non mais c'est pas massif
comme phénomène ya pas tous les jours
qu'un cri un sommet c'est pas massif
c'est pas c'est pas tous les jours que
dieu fait que des juifs et jean desfonds
beaucoup viennent de vienne me voir pour
me dire je me suis fait traiter de sale
[ __ ] donc c'est régulier quand même
nom mais jouit tout l'amour et votre
expérience est ce que vous nous
renseigner sur ce qui se passe
pratiquement qu'on sorte un peu la
théorie gens continue le tour de table
de nos invités avec vous sihem souid
vous êtes ancienne policière présidente
de la société de conseil en
communication et relations publiques
édiles consulting et pour vous c'est
très clair la notion de racisme anti
blanc n'a aucun rapport avec le racisme
dont peuvent être victimes les minorités
donc le racisme anti blanc n'existe pas
c'est un peu contradictoire d'ailleurs
votre vous dites y'a pas de rapport mais
ça peut exister quand même alors même si
c'est pas exactement la même violence et
des violences cdma cadet il ya des
personnes blanches qui sont victimes de
violences après ce n'est pas un racisme
c'est quoi le racisme c'est une ce sont
des discriminations des personnes
victimes de discrimination en raison de
leurs origines supposées ou réelles ou
de leur couleur de peau alors est ce
qu'aujourd'hui une personne blanche et
refusés à l'entrée d'une boîte de nuit
pour sa couleur ou pour un logement pour
sa couleur ou d'un emploi par rapport à
sa couleur non
mais quand vous entendez les cas qui
sont soulevées par m goldman est quand
même les quatre étudiants quelqu'un qui
vient là et c'est insulter bon sac
passer à table c'est une minorité il n'a
pas été repoussé d'une mois deux nuls et
une minorité c'est une minorité mois
pour moi c'est une minorité ce n'est pas
la majorité et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
quand j'avais maddox et pax est pas la
majorité parce que je pense qu'ils ont
peur aujourd'hui qu'ils sont blancs bien
mais non aujourd'hui on n'a pas vu les
barrières étaient donc honnêtement les
amènera des condamnés il existe des
actes anti blanc il existait aussi des
personnes qui ont été condamnées pour du
racisme anti blanc on a 47 % des
français qui considèrent que ce
processus existants pour la clarté du
débat gens présents dans cette alice
cordier vous êtes militante et
présidente du collectif nemesis un
collectif féministe identitaire ça veut
dire quoi c'est l'euphémisme droite au
nom du nom s'est faite aux femmes
puisque les françaises connaissent le
nom leur quotidien c'est tout on est on
est confronté aujourd'hui à des
problématiques et d'ailleurs vous parlez
de droite mais céline pina je crois que
c'est une écrivaine de gauche et qui
elle parle du fait notamment que
certaines femmes qui ne portent pas le
voile dans certains dans certaines
contrées de france je dirais sont
discriminés et elle n'ose plus sortir
sans le voile est ce que ça ce ne serait
pas une preuve d'amour troisième
question non j'ai juste finir si c'est
une question à vous j'ai juste finir
s'il vous plaît au sol vous passait plus
vraiment et que moi donc voila l on a
pour finir de monter raison sur une
chose sur laquelle on peut être d'accord
c'est ça ou pas c'est moins souvent
aller c'est un commercial et par rapport
à ça on ressent moins en tant que femme
blanc je ressens une crainte dans
l'espace public dans certaines zones
évidemment parce que oui il existe un
racisme anti blanc
voilà et nommer les choses c'est bien
c'est juste pas de racines c'est pas dur
et non celles décédées violence bientôt
nommer les choses non il faut nommer les
choses étaient bien vous n'êtes pas
d'accord que s'est créé de la
discrimination en fonction d'une rafale
du score du film originel avoir peur
dans la rue c'est pas une discrimination
le fait que je puisse pas m'en tombent à
l'aide d'un scanner sur la pac live
c'est la ville discrimination madame
vous savez moi j'ai peur pour ma vie
certains n'ont pas d'emploi d'accord ok
c'est du racisme et je le reconnais
entièrement il ya du racisme en france
envers les noirs envers les arabes
envers les chinois envers les
communautés asiatiques y en a pour tout
le monde est là aussi pour les français
est aujourd'hui les français ils ont
perdu vise autant les français peuvent
être aussi ne pas ne sont pas forcément
là c'est la question que je voulais vous
la question diriez vous poser c'est le
collège m goal d'arrêt m goal danel par
annie que les réunions n'ont mis que
c'était quelque chose qu'il révulsait
est ce qu il ya de la mixité raciale
dans votre collectif oui totalement
pourrait vite à le visiter viendrez vous
viendra j'aimerais bien franchement
j'aimerais bien
y faire un tout petit peu mais bon j'ai
moins de deux secondes alice cordier ça
s'apprend quelle forme ces
discriminations faut être précis
aujourd'hui ce soit je sais qu'on sorte
de la théorie pour des cas pratiques les
illustrations pratiquement ce sont
quatre ans qui regardent le sava par
aurélien tâche et visiblement blanc doit
pas habiter à peu près dans les mêmes
endroits pour acheter du côté du tarif
unique c'est une question de revenus
chacun de la même région et du coup pour
pour expliquer un tout petit peu ça va
être de l'insultent ça va être de la
menace ça va être de la violence
psychologique parce qu'elle existe aussi
cette pression le fait voilà de sentir
discriminés consorts sans voile ça peut
être ça aussi c'est une forme de
violence et une violence qui existe et
je pense qu'on devrait un tout petit peu
plus la regarder aussi donc ça va être
voilà c'est quelque chose de violent à
ces voix là mais ça peut être aussi
assez douces avec moi dans ma classe on
m'appelait la blanche parce que j'étais
la seule blanche de ma classe mais je
suis désolé moi j'ai pas j'ai pas aimé
qu'on me limite à ma couleur de peau je
pense que c'est autre chose la blanche
c'est pas une agression inadmissible a
bloqué une agression inadmissible mais
moi je réalisais la noire dans le
challenger de surbiton la situation
inverse on presse de blanc avec une
noire j'aurais appelé la noire à mon
avis je pense que toulouse sur place
nous sommes d'accord voilà donc je vais
vraiment derrière répondu oui qui
détailla juste deux ou trois mille ans
d'éclat mais non pas le détail près les
détails près moi j'suis pas responsable
de l'esclave jaurès ippon
alliés qui avaient la parole en fait
traiter quelqu'un de sel blanc c'est
inadmissible autant que traiter
quelqu'un de sale noir ou saleh ça doit
être condamné de la manière mais c'est
dur et non mais j'ai aimé finir si vous
permettez à ne pas accepter si vous
voulez qu'on condamne et qu'on considère
que c'est raciste de dire ça le blanc si
vous voulez c'est insulter une seconde
fois les victimes et quand vous dites
que quand on est blanc on n'a pas de
problème pour trouver un travail il y à
des recrutements communautaire dans
plusieurs entreprises en france il y à
des recrutements qui sont liées
justement à la communauté voire à la
communauté religieuse et je pourrais je
vais pas faire un einstein ce soir sur
le plateau pour le dire non mais non je
vais je fais ce que tu as déjà mais
comme les gens ils visaient les cars
islamisée donnez moi les entreprises il
y à des entreprises
réalisent ces journalistes qui excusez
moi
prenez pas ça comme du racisme anti
blanc mais chacun son tour
s'élance et leurs tripes ça y est j'ai
débattu avec vos amis de la france a
soumise le racisme anti blanc ils
peuvent pas considérer ce n'est pas une
de ces raisons je voudrais florence aie
aie aie août sont en cours actuel ça qu
il y à des recrutements communautaire et
auquel entrepris d'arroser dans des
entreprises notamment de transport et
même des recrutements audi vous je ne
verrais est à dire le transfert il
faudrait c'est quoi c'est la ratp fo
ratp en fait des recrutements que nous
avons des recrutements religieux donc on
ne peut pas nier et d'oublier le racisme
anti blanc c'est de la même façon si
vous voulez dire qu'on a le droit aussi
d'être raciste de manière générale vous
faites une erreur si vous voulez
vraiment que ce racisme c'est ce de
manière générale considérer que le
racisme anti blanc existe et en plus se
tient en sont victimes ce sont pas les
grands bourgeois parisien ce sont les
gens qui vivent dans des quartiers et
qui sont souvent pas la race supérieure
ou la race dominante mais simplement des
gens qui se battent qui bossent et qui
sont traités de sales blancs quand ils
sortent de chez eux et ça tant voulu
venir et vous permettra aux autres
d'être raciste dans la même façon et de
traiter les gens de sale noir ou de sale
arabe la mairie au giallo qui répondent
non alors moi je réponds non pas pour
nier les violences qui existent moi je
pense vraiment qu à des personnes qui du
fait de leur apparence qui sont
considérés enfin présumé blanc etc sont
victimes de mentalité de violence
d'injustice a certes inacceptable sa 15e
vous la refusez de vous dire que je suis
enfant et s'est terminée comme un
fardeau neymar un viol oui mais je
trouve inacceptable que c'est votre
ampli je voulais vous allez vous dire
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord elle restera
la même on est quand même mais je
connais
elle ne changera pas d'opinion que ça ne
sert à rien on est bon on n'est pas
d'accord bon ben c'est très bien c'est
la liberté c'est à dire se développer ce
que je dis c'est qu'il ya une haine qui
est condamnable et que je condamne je
comprends tout à fait que des personnes
portent plainte contre ça - fait mal
c'est délicat c'est délicat de faire de
la pédagogie quand il ya des souffrances
réelles est vraiment ma jeu je suis
révulsé par ses souffrances et j'exprime
vraiment la solidarité aux personnes qui
ont été victimes d'attaqués du fait de
leur attaquant paul mois à fait ma ma
comment dire le point que je vais
apporter ces prénoms sur la question du
vocabulaire le terme de racisme en fait
pour moi il s'inscrit dans une histoire
quand on parle de racisme on parle d'
idéologie qui ont été fondés il y à
quelques centaines d'années pour dominer
des groupes ces idéologies ont produit
l'esclavagé la colonisation des
génocides et ont des conséquences
aujourd'hui dans la représentation des
groupes qui ont été victimes de racisme
et ondées traduction institutionnelle
c'est à dire que toutes les personnes
minoritaires aujourd'hui en france qui
ne sont pas blanches en fait on est à un
moment de leur vie se sont vus rappeler
leur couleur de peau de manière négative
donc c'est une expérience collective et
ça que j'appelle racisme donc moi je
n'ai pas de problème à désigner là n tu
peux viser des personnes blanches qui
sur le terme de racisme que je veux
discuter parce que je compte que ça ni
justement ce à quoi et à appuyer la
terminologie raciste est comme si on
disait que des personnes par exemple si
un homme est victime d'injures du fait
de sa masculinité on dit c'est du
sexisme et bien ça pour moi c'est un
visibiliser la structure sexistes le
patriarcat dont sont victimes les femmes
et et voilà c'est pour ça que moi je dis
non je ne lis pas encore une fois je
n'ai pas la haine et la violence mais
c'est sur le terme qui pour moi un
visibilis des pratiques qui sont
beaucoup plus protéiforme beaucoup plus
importante et qui ont des traductions
institutionnel c'est à dire que quand on
n'est pas blanc en france on peut aussi
subir du vieux du racisme du fait
d'institutions ce n'est pas le cas pour
des personnes blanches aucune personne
blanche doit être ciblée par par exemple
des déçus des contrôles au faciès ou des
choses comme ça qui relève de la
république et de l'institut sur un an